hi everyone I'm super excited to be here
thank you very much recommend me my name
is Andrew and the founder of Haagen L we
are in the algorithmic trading startup
in a foreign exchange market together
with a couple of my friends we have been
developing a proprietary trading
algorithms for the past four years and
my research is about bacon networks and
data mining applications in the foreign
exchange market I deal with a lot of
Trento segregation and zigzag indicators
so if you are interested in this stuff
we have published our production data
another mic and in cargo there is a
simple kernel out there you can check
this one out this is a paper I published
together with my academic supervisor dr.
Mohammed on retail networks because we
love based on networks we use them in
our and symbol of occupiers so my goal
here is to make a simple introduction to
the world of algorithmic trading in
Python I'm going to share you with you
some frameworks and tools I'm going to
show you my ongoing
submission for Nomura and Nomura is a
kind of a Keagle competition with the
weekly round and in in a way just hedge
hedge fund out where data scientist I'm
going to show you a simple trading
algorithm based on machine learning for
Kentuckian and most importantly I would
love to provoke you and make you
inspired about creating alphas creating
trading strategies and just investing
your money in a more sophisticated way
so what is algorithmic trading I believe
most of you are familiar with this but
let's recap so basically it's the
automated execution of some trading
algorithm it could be something very
complicated it could be something very
simple well in a way I just cut the
investing some index like ETF follows
the S&P 500 or some dates indices and
you would probably be okay or you could
try to create the edge so algorithmic
trading is all about alpha alpha is your
strategy is your technical idea in your
edge is how
how you are able to on average make more
money than some index so we also
differentiate out ethnic trading by
high-frequency trading and low frequency
trading and plus we differentiate by
technical and fundamental analysis so
technical analysis is all about price
data and historical analysis of price
data fundamental analysis is all about
the news politics etc and the ultimate
systems are usually diffusion above so
once you combine technical indicators
and fundamental analysis it's the best
kind of but we are more oriented on the
technical analysis so we believe there
is a market Markov property in the
market and we try to model them the
markets in terms of whether the price is
going up or down so we are more to
technical analysis so how do you
actually make money in algorithmic
trading so this is a nice summary by max
demand by the way a lot of references
are presented at the end of this
presentation I'm going to show you them
so what sorry I was not
a lot of money think about hi Rico with
a lot of positions a lot of trades the
law of large numbers you will have to
have you will have to make a lot of
positions to to gain a profit so this is
a bit complicated so let's target model
base directional and arbitrage so
model-based directional think about them
as classification and regression
problems so the model-based you are
building a regression model and you are
predicting the next close price for some
asset directional is basically a
classification problem so you're
deciding whether the asset is going up
or down arbitrage is just exploiting the
market is the ability to buy and sell
the same stuff within different arenas
and once you have even a minor change in
price the cumulative some of these minor
differences is a lot of money we have
more complicated ways to make money such
as the relative value which is a fair
trading you can sometimes buy and sell
the same or acids that are Co integrated
and correlated market making you can
sometimes get within the difference
between the bid and ask and carry
trading is extremely popular in the FX
market you've just taken loans loans or
of one currency and you are expecting
that currency to go up and also take the
advantage of the interest rate so as you
can see as data scientists we can pretty
easily target model based and
directional right once again
classification and regression and so how
how does the data look so usually the
top looks like this you will have some
day time obviously open high low close
vectors sometimes you will have volume
in the FX market you do not actually
have volume because well there is no
centralized bank or alternative in the
FX market so in the stocks market volume
sometimes could be the volume in dollars
like how
much was traded the day and the adjusted
clothes is the kind of a normalized
price because stocks have dividend
splits and stuff like that so this this
is one of the most beautiful things
about algorithmic trading think about it
the feature engineering here is is a
complete art like this is your old data
and from this one you can create a lot
of technical indicators and meta
features and aggregations a lot of cool
stuff so as a retail trader and where do
you actually can get some data so there
are a couple of sources Yahoo Finance
and cuando cuando have an amazing API
it's kind of a wrapper for various data
sets you have stocks futures historical
price data for currencies if you are
more interested in the FX market so
metatrader5 would probably be your best
friend because you can use flat files
and write a data down cuando peon which
is unifying the platform I'm going to
show you an example for the squanto can
also provides a proprietary data so you
cannot download the data but you can
analyze it create some notebooks and
create a trading strategy so some tools
and set up for that a retail trader yeah
but once again you can aggregate all of
the indicators that basis Imperium so we
can basically create infinite number of
features its signatures so some tools
please know that pandas yes
oh you are entering to the idea for
startup to make a crowdfunded hedge fund
so all the people so not going to make
it commercial but speak to me so some
tools please know that pandas originally
was developed by a QR which is a huge
investment management fund like so all
the all of the functions like a person
change shift and commodity some are well
targeting quantitative finance if you're
interested in technical analysis you
have the TA lead and couple of open
source projects by a Kentuckian
radically decline by for ian's alpha
lines which are already integrated in a
way in Kentuckian so what is Kentuckian
actually so I would definitely recommend
if you're starting with algorithmic
trading this is your best place to start
and this this is the largest one
community in the world currently so it's
a platform as a service that provides
you the ability to analyze data create
vital notebooks analyze historical data
best test it and eventually even connect
your own paper trading account and real
money and they also first ongoing their
competitions and it lasts six months and
if your if your results are good enough
you can even get funded and on the other
spectrum of algorithmic trading and
quantitative finance you can find the
right and by the way who is here
familiar with the right yes so number is
kind of a hedge fund of data scientists
they use one meta model which is a
combination of your submissions and they
trade Bitcoin and as as always if your
model if your models are good enough and
you generalize well you are getting paid
Bitcoin and recently like ten months ago
they have introduced a number I read and
this number I really is the new
cryptocurrency which is for the mutual
interest of the community to to get
better models so and if you are making a
lot of
emissions which are not excellent but
they're good you're getting more number
Irie because the port your fault and the
mutual Authority is higher so this is
very important so by solving and binary
classification problem you can just make
money in quantitative finance this is a
very interesting stuff and please know
that they claim that ten thousand of
dollars today will become millions in
the following years and think about it
for a second
Bitcoin a couple of years ago and nobody
actually believed in it and now Bitcoin
is almost gold so let's take this one
seriously I'm going to show you a simple
example for memorize emission so now for
the example
so this is my ongoing solution for a new
bike
nothing fancy here so just let's go over
that quickly
so basically I load some data extract ID
this is a binary classification problem
the submission is in probabilities the
metric is the locals so one issue here
as you can see we have pretty much the
same number of club the distribution of
the closest pyramids pretty much the
same one very well-known problem here is
the divergence in the train set and the
test set so there is a difference so
what we usually do in such cases is we
try we try to build a classifier and
separate train data and test data this
is what I do here and as you can see we
can pretty much easily separate train
data from test data so basically what it
tells is it violates iid right so I'm
making some modeling and then my test
data is completely different so what
what what I try to do here is to make a
classifier and show how and didn't get
you
even if you shuffle the data you still
can separate the train test and test it
and you don't have a timestamp here you
do not actually know that the data is
time series you probably time series but
I think you get it already shuttle let's
see so this is how the data looks like
you can see it's between 0 1 and in
binary target this is your competition
data this is what you download from the
MRI each and every week and your target
is a binary class no of course not
from the probabilities it seems like
being a solving the problem of whether
the price of the bitcoin is going up or
down never I do not officially talk
about it but they claim that they are
using this data for trading Bitcoin and
no one knows actually what is the time
frame so it's kind of a Keagle so after
trying to separate the train and test
data so you can see that taking a 75th
percentile of the data and well now I
have pretty much a better picture of the
data and then the region add the usual
stuff
so yeah I had a new target variable
which I call the Train like here and
then I just labeled the train that on is
being trained and tough data as test
without the class variable of course and
then I try to separate the data and I
take any instances that have the
probability of being in the test dataset
so of course scores correct correct
this is a knowing a known issue here so
this is what I do so and then the usual
stuff want so some feature engineering
some data pre-processing you know
feature importance the usual stacking
nothing fancy here cross-validation and
out of fold predictions eventually the
data looks like this so you have a lot
of classifiers and you basically
register the probabilities for both of
the classes you have a column for the
outcome itself you can see here and this
one goes into this tracker logistic
regression models are usually the best
to use sometimes some neural nets are
performing better and eventually what I
have here is and you can see a cross
validation of score of six nine nine to
eight and then I go to memorize looks
like this so here I basically make my
submission as you can see number one
currently hold six nine two so the
battle here is about the fourth they get
sometimes it's even the fifth
and eventually top 100 participants are
in the money in each and every week you
are getting you're getting paid in
dollars and most importantly is if you
hold this position for and normalized
year you that this is the money that you
will get okay so once again it's
important to note as they claim that
currently profits of ten thousands will
become millions because this is the
unique stuff there is no one that is
doing stuff like Numa right and I
believe that more number I like sites
will appear so now I want to show you a
simple trading algorithm for quant opium
so this is the quant opium framework
this is how it looks like as you can see
it is a complete IDE okay you can back
test it here let's run a simple that
test and meanwhile I'm gonna woo alright
yeah so this is a vector of the training
algorithm so let's go over that briefly
so as you can see this is a complete IDE
plus I have a research environment that
looks like notebook right this is within
front of you here I have access to
proprietary data by point of view a lot
of good stuff a lot of you know like the
basic stuff number is fond of key lead
and here here I just I put some stuff so
you can see I already have scikit-learn
I get some data here I create a class
variable basically my idea here is to
once again the market holds Markov
property so I'm trying to classify the
next trend whether the price is going up
or down by the previous bar the data I
have here you can see open high/low
clothes and date
here I create the class variable add
some features feature engineering by
using technical indicators and simple
moving averages and stuff like that so
then I create my training list so here I
select my asset that I would love to
trade you can see facebook facebook
amazon an applic Apple Home Depot teen
visa so make some filtering sometimes
you cannot trade stuff you can basically
make here anything you can schedule
stuff you can make some pre-processing
before the market starts you can decide
when to trade like is it going to be the
flows of the day they open up the market
stuff like that so you can see that here
I make make a schedule and to trade one
hour after after a market open so here
as you can see a train here a train my
classifier
I'll make my classifier here fit it and
set it aside this is redic and then when
market opens I decide I get a
probability for the outcome and if this
probability is higher than some
threshold and basically getting into the
market and this is how I check for
signals in this particular stuff I
decided to use one-sided strategy which
means only buy and once once the signal
is a we can just sign out of the market
it's like chess and two trunk sometimes
it's better not to trade so this is the
case you and eventually some trading
function you can once again you can take
your balance you can make some
sophisticated stuff here I decided to
trade just at a constant volume and
eventually the backtest of this
algorithm looks like this so that you
can see here we have a lot of metrics
alpha beta Sharpe ratio think about them
like you know like you see precision
Rico this is there is a mapping between
them so basically it says that within
lower volatility compared to the index
which is pipe very well known ETF that
follows the S&P 500 within a lower risk
I basically made 70% more on average
than the index eventually double in my
investment so yes no the benchmark is
usually is something that is well
established like a lot of years like spy
I think exists usually you use the
indices such as spy and the XY qqq's and
stuff that is there based a lot more
years than companies even like trading
we have English in there probably still
around for a while
there is something like this it exists
among little collection in like what you
train with of course of course it's my
next slide and there is a lot of there
is a lot of philosophical stuff in this
and I would love to make a summary here
and think about it's a sad problem of
course so this is here I'm gonna talk
about this in a minute so let me just
recap what is the real view start simple
start with simple idea and the data is
out there it's pretty simple to get
quando is free to use you can get a
historical data for much of the equities
and develop some outfits be careful
because the data is time serious you
know like regular stuff out-of-sample
and so you will have to compare your
performance to some benchmarks like
despite once again because pi is the
usual and index for equities and paper
trade it will try them dem accounts okay
so if you are not able to make money on
paper trade and so you want to click
then you can live traded with small
amounts you can connect Interactive
Brokers with quanto peon and each raid
also grow your risk and repeat this flow
well because the alpha stand -
disappears marketing efficiencies
disappear all the time you will have to
reinvent the wheel and try new stuff new
trading ideas all the time so in a
philosophical aspect of this it's a sad
problem ok it's a non-deterministic
polynomial problem but please know that
we actually have some Oracle's here we
have amazing traders so it's it solvable
but it takes years to master so in a way
there are a lot of resources out there
regarding trading
great start by Coursera as always and
some podcasts and you can even try to
trade by yourself see how it goes by
investor mobile app and then stuff and
quantities finance if you are more
serious into the Python into the
algorithmic aspect of this I strongly
recommend the computational investment
by Georgia Tech by a soccer bulge and
max damage is basically the best paper
on algorithmic trading it's an amazing
summary some tools and that's all folks
question yeah depends on how large the
volume it's a good aspect so if you are
a hedge fund
you're probably in there in problems but
there are a lot of methods to avoid it
like we were tee what you can slice your
trade if you're making some big trades
you can slide them down to separate them
and stuff like that so what you showed
here if anything correctly is not high
frequency no of course not you collect
all the baby bases like what is your
current daily only four hours not a lot
of trades within microseconds or stuff
like that did you guys try to do like
not like without really understanding
their features like taking that the raw
data we do it with images through deep
network and to try to
yeah we have more than 1400 features and
usually we left out with 10 to 20 meters
so the feature selection of course is a
waggle pun oh great combination the real
star in the usual will run for logistic
regression a couple of algorithms for
Bayesian networks various search
algorithms would be Bayesian networks
because this is all about probability so
a probabilistic approach to this is very
powerful and sometimes even stuff like
neighbors so combination and something
like 10 classifiers nothing within
special yeah because major networks and
this is the paper that we have published
we are a couple of wants an elite we
have been dealing with this stuff for
the past four years we trade with our
own money we have multiple trading
accounts within FX brokers and currently
we are trading with interactive brokers
for equities we are constantly looking
for investment and you have ideas and
stuff like that and as I mentioned our
goal is to make basically a hedge fund
and crowdfunded hedge fund because
anyone have a little bit of money and if
you can buy this money you can have a
lot of money and trade with that so this
is our vision with it thanks
you